Hi guys, my name is Heinrich
and welcome to another coffee
break with Firm Learning.
I hope you're all having a good time.
Today I'm talking about
how you can actually
bring skills to your
employer, to the workplace,
even as a new business joiner.
Even if you're just
freshly out of university.
And why is all of this
even relevant at all?
Well the truth is that usually
if you start at a new place
you are at a big disadvantage
in many areas of your work.
If you work in IT you first need
to learn the system architecture
that you're working with.
You need to learn the stack
that the company is using.
It will take you quite some time
until you're up to speed
and you will usually
be at a big disadvantage
compared to all the other professionals
working in your field.
Pretty similar if you work in law.
If you're a lawyer.
You may come from
university where you learnt
lots of theoretical knowledge
but then being in a law firm.
Working on, for instance corporate law,
getting all the things done,
knowing how all the things
are actually done in practice
will take you quite some time
maybe years to learn
until you're at a level
where you're on par with other
professionals in your field.
And of course, if you're a
normal business practitioner
this is very similar as well.
You might work with certain tools,
with certain software.
There's a certain
architecture that the people
are working with.
And it will take you quite some time
until you catch up and really understand
all the business processes to a level
that other people in the organization
who maybe worked there
already for several years.
However, all these things being said,
from my experience after
many years in consulting
I believe that there
are two technical skills
that you can learn pretty
quickly as a new joiner
and if you do you usually, at
least in these specific areas,
add a significant advantage
compared to other people
working in your organization.
And these two technical skills are first,
PowerPoint, being good in PowerPoint
and second, Excel, being
good at Microsoft Excel.
So let's talk about these two.
Why are they relevant?
Why do I believe that this can really
make a difference for
your professional life?
And what can you actually do
to build this skillset
and improve your skills?
Let's start with PowerPoint.
The truth is that pretty much
all larger corporations
and also most of the SMEs,
the small and medium-sized enterprises
use PowerPoint on a daily basis
in almost all of their business functions.
And of course on the one-hand side
this is for internal presentations,
for internal communication
but then on the other side
also from communication
for external stakeholders like customers,
like banks or other investors
or any other stakeholder that might be.
And you can imagine especially
for this latter type
of presentations it is super crucial
and pretty much always
in the highest interest
of the C level executives in your company
that these presentations are getting done
at the highest professional level
and they're meeting really
the highest out there.
If you imagine that usually
the sea of offerances
need to present something
in front of investors,
in front of banks,
he wants to make sure
that the things he present
not only in the terms of the
content that he's showing
but also the style, the formal appearance
of the presentation is as professional
as it can be.
Similar to anything relating
to sales presentations
in front of customers
or other things that might happen,
other stakeholders that
might be out there.
And the other truth is
that in a corporation
from my experience having worked
with many German corporations
but also other corporations
throughout Europe
and also in other continents,
very, very few people in an organization,
even in a large blue chip company
have the skill to create
PowerPoint presentations
in a way that this really meets
this highest of standards.
Yes it's true that many
people have some basic skills
and can create some slides,
but these slides are not at a level
that you would expect them
if for instance you work
in a large consulting firm
like McKinsey or BCG where
these are really skills
that are valued and skills are developed
and honed over time.
So what does this mean for you?
If you can bring these
PowerPoint skills to the table,
if you can get to a level
where you are better
in creating PowerPoint pages
than almost all other people
in the organization,
this can be a huge advantage for you
up to the point that even the CEO,
the C level executives of your company
want to work together with you
even as a junior colleague
because you can help them
to get these presentations
to a level where it's really making
a difference for these people.
And if you are at the point
you suddenly have exposure
to the most important,
most senior projects
that your specific employer is working on
and you have direct exposure
to these C level executives
where other people might
need years and years
until they are at a point
where this might be possible.
And again, from my experience
from what I have experienced
it is not that difficult to get there.
I've seen junior colleagues
learn these skills
in a quite short amount of time
and then being sought after
by these senior people in organization.
So what can you actually do
in order to improve your
skills in PowerPoint?
Well of course one point is always
learning by doing.
The more presentations you
do, the better you will get.
But then the other point is also
that you need some kind of guidance.
You need to know how presentations
in front of senior investors,
senior customers on board levels,
how these presentations
actually need to look like
because if you have nobody
giving you that coaching
that you get in consulting,
you just cannot get there, right?
Because you have no
guidance in how to do that.
And of course you can ask other people
who have done that.
You can look at
presentations if you get some
of that senior level in your company
where you see how these
are supposed to look like
and of course the value that I can bring
is in this channel that if
you look into the play lists
if you look in prior videos
I will link a few of them here above,
I'm talking about these skills.
I'm actually teaching
in several of my videos
what you need to do in order
to get your presentations
at that level.
So feel free to look at these videos
and if you're really serious
in developing these skills
I actually created a full course,
a full online course
based on my experience
working for over six years at McKinsey
on how to create C level
type slide presentations.
There's a link to this course
in the video description below.
Don't just take my word for it
that it's actually pretty good.
Look into the reviews
that many other people
are giving on the course.
I have over ten thousand students
who took that course
so if you want to learn more
check out the link into the description
and see if this course might be something
that actually adds value to you.
The second are where I
believe you can quickly
add significant amounts of value
to your organization as a new joiner
is Excel.
Skills in Microsoft Excel.
Excel is pretty much similar to PowerPoint
in the way that it's used
by almost every organization out there.
While it is true that some alternatives
like Altaviz of Tableau
for data visualization
are being used more and more,
Excel is the definite standard
on working with data hands down, right?
There's no software that is globally used
the way that Excel does.
No software where you
can have so much impact
in many organizations just
that you can have with Excel.
And again, from my experience
even working in really super
large blue chip companies,
many, many people lack
basic skills in Excel
that if they would have them
would really make a
difference in your work.
And this of course depends
a lot on the department.
If you work in management accounting,
if you work in a controlling department
yes their people usually
will be quite advanced.
But on average people
do not have the skills
and yes, while they can
do some basic things,
they will usually not be able to build
more complex models, to
build more complex dashboards
that might really help.
And this is actually
something that in consulting
people do quite often.
As a consultant you go into a corporation
and while you work on certain
tasks you were asked to do
pretty frequently they also end up
building a couple of models
or a couple of Excel dashboards
that basically just as a bi-product
you give to the client to really help them
because you just see
the way they're working
and you just realize,
this is just so crazy
that they do not just have
that in an Excel model
that you can just update regularly,
pretty much automatically.
But you just see them
how they super manually
build together reports
and you just can't believe that
this is what they're doing.
And then you try to help them.
But this is actually what happens.
And as a new joiner this is
actually an opportunity for you
because you can be the
one for your department
now builds this model that
actually really saves time
because before several other colleagues
needed to manually compile certain files.
You just figured out that
based on a data output
you get off one of your systems
you can just compile a
dashboard out of that
that really adds value to
the people you work with.
Usually Excel skills
are always sought after.
If your team leader, manager, realizes
that you are good in Excel
and you can build certain
things this will help you.
He will seek to work with you
because you can really make
a difference in his life.
So yes, building Excel
skills is important.
I really encourage you to do that
and again, how can you
actually develop your skills?
Here from my experience
even more than in PowerPoint
it's true learning by doing.
You try to solve certain problems in Excel
then you will get stuck
then you will google that.
You will try to read of
what you can actually do
and then by that you learn, oh, okay.
There's this formula that I can use
to solve that problem.
And then over time you will develop
your repertoire, things that you can do.
And I encourage you, just get your hands
on that, start learning,
and do these things.
And now I have a question for you.
Because I was wondering whether actually
videos on the content of Excel
on how you can use Excel in a very
practical way to build certain models
that you will frequently need to build.
Whether this is content
that would interest you.
Would these be videos that you
would be interested to
see on this channel?
Let me know, just write a few comments.
Because I'm thinking
about making these videos.
But it would be great for me to know
whether actually there is an interest.
Whether you care.
Whether you would like to see more
about this type of stuff.
So let me know,
I would very much
appreciate your feedback.
I have a couple of ideas that I believe
would be really valuable
and would help you to
develop the Access skills.
So to summarize,
developing your skills
in PowerPoint and Excel
from my experience is a skills
that is relevant in pretty much
every industry you work on
and pretty much every
function you work on.
And I believe that there are only
very few things that you can learn
in terms of skills that will be
as broadly applicable
that skills in PowerPoint and Excel are
and, therefore, as valuable for you
as a new joiner.
So whenever you have an opportunity
to work with these things
to develop your skills
I can only encourage you
to really do that
and to seek out additional
material out there
in order to improve
the skills that, again,
I made a course on PowerPoint
skills on working with PowerPoint
as top management consultants would do.
Check out the description to learn more.
And if you took some
value out of this video
please press the like button.
And if you would like to learn more
about things that you can do
to improve your career,
and the early years of your career,
press the subscribe button
to stay up to day with all
the content on this channel.
Thank you for watching.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.